FELIPE HOFFA: And
hello, everyone.
Thank you for staying-- last
talk of Google I/O 2014.
It's been a long road,
but we are almost done.
Predicting the future with
the Google Cloud Platform,
that's what we want to do
today, what we want to show you.
The first question is, why?
Why now?
And it turns out that we never
had so much data in the world.
It's really impressive how
much data we can collect.
Just going to I/O last year,
we had this presentation,
"All the Ships in the
World," where we showed you
how you were able to just
map and visualize and collect
all this data.
All the teams that's how they
are moving around the world.
And a month ago, we
released this data
set with Professor
[INAUDIBLE], over a quarter
billion events all around the
world for the last 30 years
detailing everything
important that
is happening around the world.
But we cannot only look at
things at the world level.
We can zoom into
particular regions,
let's say South America
or particular countries
like Brazil.
Something important
might be happening there.
Let's zoom in further.
Let's go through any city--
Fortaleza, for example,
just to show you
examples of cities.
Recently, our friend
Eric demoed how
to stream all the powered
meters inside a city
up to be queried with
50,000 rows per second.
But let's zoom in to a
particular place today.
Let's go to this stadium.
And we can travel to the
past with Street View.
We can see how this stadium
was being constructed.
We have all this data.
We are collecting everything
that is happening.
But the question
today is, can we
use this data to
predict what is going
to happen inside this
place during the 90
minutes of a match?
Well, your presenters--
and today, here we
have Jordan Tigani.
He is one of the founding
members of the BigQuery team.
He also wrote the
book on BigQuery.
If you stay and go to him,
he will give you a copy
and sign it too.
And I'm Felipe Hoffa.
I work with Google
developer relations.
My job here is to do exactly
this-- to bring you the Google
technologies that you
can use and show you
what you can do so you can
put them for your own use.
So let's go to our topic
today-- predictions.
We have been doing this for a
long time-- thousands of years.
And people have
used crystal balls.
More recently, for
the last World Cup,
this octopus did pretty well.
He got like 11 of
13 matches right.
We're not sure why or how.
It seems he really
liked the Germany flag.
But we don't know.
We can't ask him, anymore.
But we're going to use data.
And that's what we have.
When you want data,
the first place
you go to search for
it-- for me it's Google.
And some of the
interesting data sets
I got were, for
example, the Wikipedia.
Wikipedia has a
lot of knowledge.
But then, it's hard to put this
data into learning algorithms.
But fortunately,
we have Freebase.
Freebase is a
Google project that
engulfs a lot of this knowledge
as fact in SQL, in a table,
in an RDF table.
And we can use these facts.
There are like a
million facts there
of the World Cup,
players, teams.
I also found this
other open data
set that people are
building on this on GitHub
with all the
information from soccer
matches, from history,
from around the world,
from the World Cup.
So I got back.
I got Freebase.
I was able to use
this data for example
to find correlations like,
do countries with a bigger
population do better in
the World Cup or not?
Ask me later about
that, because I really
want to go to the next topic.
That's Opta.
This is a pretty cool data set.
It's not open.
But they are really
changing the way
that soccer can be analyzed.
For any given match,
they are recording event
by event, touch by
touch, what is happening.
Who is holding the ball?
Where is he standing?
People are able to
analyze the full history
of a player, the full
history of a soccer match,
in a very cool way.
Just to give you an example,
with this query, BigQuery,
we know there's
around 2,000 matches,
1,500 rows of information
for each match.
And here, I'm looking at
that particular match-- Spain
versus Netherlands.
I knew that there was a goal
at the particular minute-- 43.
And I wanted to know more
information about it.
And what did I get?
I got information like, when did
it happen, who was the player,
where he was located at the
moment that goal happened.
And I got a lot of details
too, like yes, this
was a header goal.
Where was the goalie standing?
Where did the ball
exactly go in?
And now I'm able
to use this data.
The question is, when
I have this data,
how can I use it to predict?
And for that, we have Jordan
our machine learning expert.
So please, Jordan.
JORDAN TIGANI: Thanks
very much, Felipe.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit
about using machine learning
to predict soccer games.
But first, I want to
talk about-- soccer is
really hard to predict.
There's a lot of randomness.
The team that's better
doesn't always win.
A lot of times you see a
team, they have the ball,
they're shooting the whole game.
The ball just ends
up not going in.
And the other team,
they get the ball once,
and they go and score and win.
AUDIENCE: Like Germany!
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes,
exactly like Germany.
This picture here is a
reenactment of a famous goal.
But just recently,
just yesterday,
the Argentina versus Nigeria
game, there was a shot.
The keeper saved it.
It went off his glove.
It hit the post, came
back, hit him in the head,
went off the post again, bounced
out in front of the goal,
and Leo Messi came and
just blasted it in.
But that's the kind of thing
that no learning algorithm
is going to be able to predict.
Just to give an idea
of how the experts do--
these are the guys whose job
it is to predict the future.
And they turn their
eye to soccer.
Nate Silver, the guy who
predicted Obama's victory as
well as lots of other
things, of the 16 teams
he predicted would make it to
the second round, only eight
are still around.
Goldman Sachs had
another prediction
using some of the same
techniques that we're using.
And they're not doing
so great-- only 36%
of their first matches.
This is not a competition.
We're not trying
to beat anybody.
We're just trying to show how
machine learning can be used
and to level set expectations.
So "O Jogo Bonito" is Portuguese
for "The Beautiful Game."
It was first attributed to
Pele talking about soccer.
Soccer is a really,
really beautiful game.
And magical things
happen on the field.
And players like Leo Messi
can do incredible things
with the ball.
Machine learning can
be magical as well.
For example, Gmail, when it
detects that all of your spam
is spam and you never
see spam anymore,
that can be pretty magical.
Or when you visit a page
in Portuguese on Chrome,
and it recognizes that and
offers to translate it,
that's another application
of machine learning.
But what I want to
get across today
is that machine
learning is not magic.
And anybody can do it.
And it's acutally sort of
rather than playing soccer
at Messi's level, it's more like
managing a team-- that somebody
can learn to do machine
learning fairly easily.
So I'm going to use an extended
metaphor about managing a team,
so just bear with
me a little bit.
So the first thing you do
whether you're managing a team
or you're doing machine learning
is you want to set a goal.
If you're the manager of
the Brazilian national team
with 200 million soccer-mad
fans and players,
you're obviously going to
want to win the World Cup.
However, if you're
the manager of Tuvalu,
a tiny island in the Pacific,
even though in theory you
could qualify and win the World
Cup, that may not be your goal.
Obviously, you still
want to win every game.
But when you're
playing Australia,
you may not assume that you're
going to win every game.
Your goal may be just to beat
Vanuatu, a neighboring island.
Similarly, with
machine learning,
you use the resources that you
have to decide the prediction
task that you're going to do.
So we have this really huge
data set-- this really deep data
set-- on club level soccer.
So we have all the
touches for three
different professional
leagues-- the English Premier
League, Spanish La Liga,
and the US Major League
Soccer over a couple years.
And we can mine
this data to build
a model of how
professional soccer works.
However, that
doesn't necessarily
help us with the World Cup.
And so we're going
to have to try
to stretch that a
little bit in order
to make our models
work for the World Cup.
Because there just
isn't the same depth
of data available there.
So once you have your data,
once you have your goals,
then you want to pick your team.
And a manager of a
team is going to want
to pick based on
certain attributes
that they believe
correlates with victory.
They want fast people up front.
They want people who can pass
well in midfield and people who
like to throw themselves on
the ground as goalkeeper.
In machine learning, the
statistics that you use-- you
want to build statistics
from your data that
correlate well with whatever
you're trying to predict.
So for the soccer
example, that may
be whether the team
takes a lot of shots,
whether the team gets the
ball in the other team's
third of the field a lot,
whether they pass well,
whether they foul a lot.
So you want to-- sorry, just
lost my train of thought.
But after you've
built your features,
after you've computed
those statistics,
the next thing you want
to do is train your team.
And the nice thing is
in machine learning,
you use the same
term as in soccer.
You train a machine
learning model.
And you train it
to find patterns.
And though that sounds
a little bit mysterious,
it's actually relatively
straightforward.
So we can show how this works
in a somewhat simple example.
So this is data that we've
gotten from our data sets
about the probability
of scoring a goal based
on how far away from the
goal the shot was taken.
And to a human eye, you
can see that there's
a clear pattern here.
But it's a little bit more
difficult to get a computer
to recognize this pattern.
So one way to do that is to
make the pattern simpler.
And if we take the
log of the distance
rather than using the
distance by itself,
we have a much more
simple pattern.
And we can use a linear
regression, which
is a statistical tool that's
present in spreadsheet packages
and people may be familiar
with, to essentially draw
a line through that data.
And people don't
necessarily think
of this as a prediction tool.
But actually, this
lets us predict,
given the distance
the shot was taken,
the probability
that that's going
to go in for any distance.
So the type of machine
learning algorithm
we are going to use here
is not linear regression,
but it's another
type of regression.
And we're just going to fit
into a different type of curve.
This is a logistic curve.
And the nice things
about it is it's
bound between 0 and 1, which
fits well for probabilities.
The other thing is that
it more easily captures
nonlinear relationships
between the data.
So for the same example of a
distance from shot on target,
we can fit a relatively
good line to that data
without having to
translate it first.
So I mentioned fitting
the line to the data.
So we're going to keep
track of a statistic.
And it's called r squared.
And it's a measure of how
close your line is to your data
points.
There's not necessarily
a good rule of thumb
for what constitutes a
good one or a bad one.
But it's a good way of comparing
two subsequent models as you're
iterating through
different ideas.
So when you're fitting
data to a model,
one thing you have to worry
about is over-fitting.
So here's three
soccer players who
have won World Footballer of
the Year in the last 15 years--
Ronaldo, Ronaldinho,
and Cristiano Ronaldo.
You may be able to detect a
pattern here in their names.
And I can come up with
a regular expression
that can capture this.
But you may not
want to turn this
into a predictive algorithm.
Or maybe you do.
So I think I can
predict who's going
to be the next World
Footballer of the Year.
He's been under everyone's
noses for the last 40 years--
Ronald McDonald,
McDonald's mascot.
Premier League Scouts, you don't
have to give me a finder's fee
but maybe some cheap
tickets would be nice.
But clearly, this is absurd.
It's a coincidence, and
machine learning algorithms
can be good at
finding coincidences.
And so the way you prevent
that from happening
is a technique called and
parsimony or Occam's razor.
And you want to find the
simplest possible explanation.
And the way you do
that in an algorithm
is you penalize complexity.
So if you try to come up
with some really bizarre,
complex model,
that model will not
score as highly as another one.
Whether you're building a
team, or your building models,
you want to keep score.
So usually when you
train your data,
you break it into two pieces.
One piece is your training
set, and the other piece
is your test set.
The training set is the
data that you actually
want to use to build the model.
The test set, on the other
hand, you keep to the side
so that you can validate
that that model is not just
regurgitating facts that it
already knows, but can actually
be used on things it
hasn't seen before.
So a metric that we use to
see how well we're doing
is called lift.
And that just tells,
how much better
are we doing than random chance?
Accuracy would be the
obvious thing to use.
But the problem
with accuracy is it
doesn't reflect
underlying probabilities.
For example, soccer has
three possible outcomes.
So if you can guess 50%
right 50% of the time,
then you're actually
doing pretty well.
But if you're just
looking at accuracy,
50% sounds like
it's a coin flip.
So lift actually lets us
measure that more accurately.
So here's another,
more complicated way
of looking at accuracy.
And this is the
receiver operator curve,
which is kind of a strange term.
But it comes from
finding U-boats
by radio detection
in World War II.
And the name stuck.
But we have this
dotted line going
from the bottom left
corner to the top right.
And that's pure luck.
So if you're right
on that line, that
means your model is terrible.
So the further you get away
from that line the better.
So I won't go into details
about what this necessarily
means, but we'll see
it a little later when
we're comparing models.
The other thing about
machine learning
is it's an iterative process.
You try it once, you keep
trying, and it may not work.
You need to sort of
put more creativity
into coming up with
good features that
are going to work for you.
So then once you have your
model, you've built the model,
you've tested it,
you've iterated on it,
you want to do the thing
that we're all here to do,
which is we want to
actually use it to predict.
And so I'm going to switch
to an iPython notebook.
And so iPython is sort
of the visualization
of a suite of scientific
tools for Python
that lets you do lots of
mathematical and scientific
programming and has some
built-in machine learning
algorithms as well.
OK, hey, it worked.
So you don't necessarily
need to understand
every line of this code.
I'm just going to go through--
this is how it would work
and this is how you can do it.
So this iPython notebook is
connected on the back end
to a Google Compute
Engine instance.
You could also connect it
to a cluster of instances.
And we did that for some of
the more hard core computation
that we have done.
It also is using a
pandas, which has
a convenient BigQuery
connector here.
You can see that with
essentially one line of code,
you can run a BigQuery and turn
it into a pandas data frame
and operate on it that way.
And generally, the
first thing you
want to do in
machine learning is
you want to get a
feel for your data.
And so we'll just see
how big our data is.
We've got over 2,000 matches,
1,700 touches per match.
And then, as Felipe showed, we
have multiple facts per touch.
And there's about 13 million
of those in our data set.
Then we want to
build our features.
And our futures are built by
this actually very complicated
BigQuery query.
It's 11,000 characters long,
15 JOINs, and eight GROUP BYs.
So I won't show that here,
because it wouldn't necessarily
be interesting.
But with BigQuery, we can
just send one giant query
to BigQuery and let it worry
about it rather than having
to sort of build a pipeline
or re-pull data down
and operate on it iteratively.
So the next step is
just run the query.
We're going to split
up the World Cup
data from the club data.
Because we want to build our
model on just the club data.
And so here's an example
of what our features look
like for-- actually, this is
the Chile-Netherlands game.
Sorry about that one, Felipe.
So the Netherlands won 2-0.
But we have the pass rates in
various parts of the field.
We have how many goals were
scored in previous games.
And actually, the
way we're doing this
is we're taking--
in order to predict
what's going to happen
in one particular game,
we're taking an average of
statistics that happened
in the last three games,
assuming that those will sort
of hold in the next game.
And if you're following
the World Cup,
you may notice that there's
a reason for that three
number, which is
right now, every team
has played exactly three games.
So we have three
games that we can
use to inform our models when
we're looking at the World Cup.
As I mentioned, again, you want
to get a feel for your data.
This is building crosstabs
of goals to whether you win,
tie, or lose.
And so we can see here
in the top left corner,
if you don't score any goals,
you're going to lose about 2/3
of the time, whereas kind
of towards the bottom right,
we see that if you
score six goals or more,
you're more or less
guaranteed to win.
The nice thing about--
this particular crosstab
helped us find a bug when
we were debugging BigQuery.
Because in the World
Cup, or in tournaments,
in the knockout stages,
if the game ends in a tie,
then it goes into penalty kicks.
And so we end up
seeing teams that
scored seven goals
who lost, which
sounds a little bit weird.
But the reason was
because in our data,
those all showed
as regular goals.
And clearly, we want to
strip those out of our data
when building the model.
So kind of playing with
the data a little bit
can help you prevent
bugs in your system.
So next, we want
to train our model.
And we're going to split
out the test set here
that we're going to
use for validation.
You can see the r squared
is about 12% on this one.
The model training also lets
us do feature selection.
And it tells us which features
turned out to be important
for that model,
which ones didn't.
So we can see the features
that correlated positively
with wins, whether you're
playing at home-- actually,
home-field advantage
is a huge deal
in soccer-- things like
how well you passed
in the opposing
third of the field.
There were some features that
were dropped that just turned
out to be not interesting all
by the Occam's razor principle--
how many fouls
your opponents had
or how many shots your opponents
had had in previous games.
And there's also
negative features,
which are features that mean
you're less likely to win.
And so opp_op_pass is a
little bit of a weird name,
but it's how well people
passed against your opponent.
Opp_expected_goals is your
opponents-- how many shots
they had and how many goals you
would've expected them to have,
et cetera.
So then we want to predict
wins in club level data.
So we run some
quick predictions.
And so here's some examples.
So we predicted Manchester
United would beat Wigan.
That's probably not a
surprise to anybody.
And we got that one right.
We predicted Manchester United
would beat Tottenham Hotspur,
which people would
expect would happen.
But actually, Tottenham
Hotspur upset Man United.
But these are sort of anecdotes.
And you want to be able to
collect these into actual data.
So we can validate this.
We can compute the
lift statistic.
So we have the lift is 41%.
So we're doing 41%
better than random.
And here's the ROC curve.
And this one isn't
necessarily that interesting
until we show the next model.
So one thing, if you're looking
at the last three games,
one problem is you may have
had three really easy games.
You may have had three
really hard games.
And so we want to be able to
coordinate those together.
And so what we do is we run
another logistic regression
that ends up stack
ranking all of the games
by sort of building a lattice
among who's better than whom
in terms of all the
teams that have played.
So we build that, do
that logistic regression,
and we compute a
power statistic.
And if you've seen the
FIFA Coca-Cola power
statistic for soccer,
or college football
has power rankings, that's
essentially how that's created.
And we're going to compute
that power ranking.
We're going to add
that back to our model
as one of our features.
So when we compute
the power statistic
and add it back to
the model, we can
see that our lift
goes from 41% to 55%.
And our ROC curve, we can
see it moves further away
from that luck
line in the middle.
The new one is the blue line.
OK, so we've
predicted club soccer,
but we want to be able
to predict the World Cup.
That's what we're here for.
So we basically have to apply
some of the same techniques
here.
There's a lot of code here,
but I wouldn't necessarily
worry about it.
And we can run the predictions.
And here's our predictions.
And before we go
too far into that,
I'm going to give
it back to Felipe.
And we'll talk more
about those in a minute.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank
you, you're done.
Let me take this.
So let's go to
half time if I can.
Where's the button?
Here.
Present.
Awesome.
So what do we have here?
What did we learn?
We know how we can
predict, use this data.
We can use iPython, pandas
to do a linear regression,
a logarithmic regression.
But do you want to know what
are our actual predictions?
For example, this Saturday, 9:00
AM, Brazil is playing Chile.
Who thinks Brazil
is going to win?
Chile?
Come on.
Machine learning
said that Brazil
will win with a 72% chance.
You were close.
Columbia versus Uruguay?
JORDAN TIGANI: I think
they're both good teams.
But now that Luis Suarez
is out for biting,
I think Columbia is
probably going to do it.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's see what
our machine learning said.
69%, OK.
Netherlands versus Mexico.
AUDIENCE: Mexico.
FELIPE HOFFA: Mexico?
JORDAN TIGANI: My guess
would be Netherlands
having seen them play Spain.
But Mexico is a good team, too.
FELIPE HOFFA: Computer
says 55% Netherlands.
We can call this
too close to call,
so we have to wait for this.
Well done, Mexico.
Costa Rica versus Greece?
JORDAN TIGANI:
That's a tough one.
I'm going to have
to go with Greece.
FELIPE HOFFA: Costa Rica, 60%.
France versus Nigeria?
JORDAN TIGANI: That
should be an easy one.
France.
FELIPE HOFFA: 92%-- that's
a lot of confidence there.
Argentina versus Switzerland?
JORDAN TIGANI: Argentina looks
hard to beat this World Cup.
FELIPE HOFFA: 68%.
Germany versus Algeria?
JORDAN TIGANI: Germany
looks even better.
FELIPE HOFFA: 93%.
Belgium versus-- Belgium?
AUDIENCE: USA.
FELIPE HOFFA: USA?
68%.
We will see.
Who will be the finalists?
I don't know.
We might try to guess.
We think it's Brazil
versus Argentina.
And the prediction is 55%, so we
can call it too close to call.
Now, whoever is watching
this video in the future
might know what all happened.
So please let me know.
You're this video.
JORDAN TIGANI: We can
always change the video.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes, we
can change the video.
So yes.
So yes, not only can
we change the view--
we're not doing that.
But things change
minute by minute.
We ran our static
predictions here.
But sometimes you might have
the best team, the best players,
and things change in
the first five minutes,
and you lose your best players.
Or one of your players
might bite too hard.
That changed the whole
outcome of the game.
And as you saw yesterday with
Eric Schmidt at the keynote--
the cool Eric Schmidt--
we are able to stream
all the data using Dataflow.
We can get second by
second what is happening.
And the question here
is, can we use that data?
The facts are changing during
every second around the world.
Can we use it?
Can we put them inside
of our prediction models?
Jordan?
JORDAN TIGANI: OK,
let's see we can do.
So you guys may have
seen in the keynote--
this is a screenshot from
the demo op that we built.
It's also been available
in the sandbox,
but this shows minute by minute
what we sort of expect to have.
So we want to build a
real-time model that'll
let us know from inside the game
who we think is going to win.
The way we're going to do
that is a Markov Monte Carlo
simulation.
And that may sound
rather confusing.
But essentially what it is
is it's just a video game.
There's a player.
He's got the ball
somewhere on the field.
And he has some options.
One option might be to pass.
One option might be to shoot.
One option might
be to get fouled.
And we compute
conditional probabilities
for each of these
possible events.
And then, we traverse
a state machine
based on the conditional
probabilities.
Then we can iterate
through that state machine
to run an entire game.
So we can see-- OK,
we run through that,
and Team A won, and
they scored three goals.
So that doesn't
necessarily tell you
too much about what
the probabilities are.
But we can get
probabilities by running
this 10,000 times in parallel.
And then each time Team A
wins, we give Team A a point.
Each time Team B wins,
we give Team B a point.
And then the we can
compute the probability
of the outcome that way.
And so this is sort
of what the Dataflow
pipeline looks like it.
Don't necessarily worry
about what those boxes mean.
So we have this data
that's coming in from Opta.
That touch by touch data, we
get that record by record.
And we can sort of
add that to our model.
So what can we do to
incorporate that data
into a machine learning model?
So what we can do is we
can use the data that's
coming in to know exactly where
we are in the game, exactly
where we are in our Monte
Carlo Markov chain model.
Sorry, I'm-- anyway, we can run
the game forward until the end.
And then we can
compute probabilities
of Team A versus Team
B winning from where
we are in the current game.
And so I can show a
quick demo of this.
This has been up at the sandbox
for the last couple days.
So you may have seen
Eric Schmidt run it.
And can you just run that?
So we're seeing basically
this Monte Carlo
running of an entire game.
And then, you can see
histograms of who's going to win
and who's not going to win.
And I think this is
Brazil versus Croatia?
I don't know.
In the sandbox, we were
showing Brazil versus Croatia.
Can we switch back?
We don't necessarily need
to wait until this is done.
FELIPE HOFFA: Go back.
JORDAN TIGANI: And that's it.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
what did we learn?
It's almost the end.
Machine learning is like
training your own team--
set a goal, pick your
features, do the training,
measure the lift,
practice, predict,
and after all that's
happening, try to understand.
Look where you can
find correlations.
And the next step is
finding [? conversation ?].
We might say that making
predictions is hard.
But it turns out
it is very easy.
We just made it.
It's harder to be right.
But it's even harder-- or
more interesting-- to make
them happen.
Because as you
understand the world,
you can use this information,
not only in soccer,
not only to win the next match.
You can use all
the data you have
to find patterns inside your
city, how your city's moving,
how the world is moving,
where things are going,
and how you can change it.
And with this data,
with these tools,
you can go from
divination to really
having the world in your hands.
Thank you very much.
Use this.
Go change the world.
[APPLAUSE]
FELIPE HOFFA: Any questions?
Thank you for staying.
I know it's over, but we have
10 minutes for questions?
Or less.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So the obvious question
is, why didn't you
use Google Prediction
API, and why did you
decide to build
your own algorithm?
JORDAN TIGANI: So
one thing I want
to say about the
Google Prediction API
is that the Google Prediction--
the underlying algorithms
are awesome.
It's actually the
Google Prediction API
uses the same technology as most
of Google's machine learning.
And it's used throughout ads,
throughout spam detection,
throughout language detection.
So it's not that-- the
prediction API is not a toy.
We didn't use it
because we wanted
to show how all the bells
and whistles worked.
So the prediction API
kind of abstracts you away
from some of the more funky
or perhaps interesting
parts of machine learning.
So we wanted to
just sort of give
a little bit of machine learning
primer as we were going.
AUDIENCE: So that
you could understand
the coefficient influence
of each feature?
JORDAN TIGANI: Yeah, and
that's one thing that you don't
get from the
prediction API is sort
of the feedback about
feature selection.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Did you compare your coefficient
versus what Google Prediction
API did, and did you do a
benchmark against these two
things?
JORDAN TIGANI: We haven't
done that, actually.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question is, what
tools, or maybe languages,
you use for past prototyping?
As I understand, it is Python.
But maybe something else?
I mean, you don't use
Google Prediction API
for your own prototyping here.
JORDAN TIGANI: So Python
is used heavily at Google.
So iPython is really nice
to be able to predict.
There's some things that are
missing in Python, pandas, et
cetera.
But the nice thing about that
is you can call into R as well.
So R has vast libraries of
scientific applications.
AUDIENCE: And a second
personal question,
I think-- what kind of data
sets do you like to learn?
Each of them.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, so I don't
exactly hear the question.
What data sets we like to--
AUDIENCE: What kind
of large data sets.
I see football
data sets that you
try to learn, or
maybe something else.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah,
look at the [? delt ?].
With the [? delt ?] you can see
what is happening in the world
right now.
Last week someone uploaded
all the taxi rides in New York
from 2013.
And just to be able to see every
pattern, how people are moving,
there are vast areas
to discover there.
I also love looking
at the Wikipedia logs.
DNA.
You can go into genetics
also with the query.
There are a lot of
impressive things you can do.
AUDIENCE: And you?
JORDAN TIGANI: Anything
I can get my hands on.
Soccer is a passion
of mine, and so I
was really excited to get the
data to be able to do this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: You get a book.
JORDAN TIGANI: You get a book.
You get a book.
AUDIENCE: My question is,
what visualization library
did you use for the animation
after the Dataflow example?
So how did you do
the visualization
from Python and pandas to the
time series thing you did.
JORDAN TIGANI: So that
was just JavaScript.
That's just raw JavaScript
that we put together
to demonstrate that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And for the prediction, did use
a library like scikit-learn?
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes, exactly.
That's what we did.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: Sure, thanks.
You get a book.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
a novice to BigQuery
and machine learning
algorithms for predictions.
So my question is, once I get my
data set migrated into big data
and some sort of
database there, and I
want to start making predictions
and figuring out patterns
in my data, how do I go about--
what machine learning algorithm
options are there
for me in order
to start putting
together those patterns
and start making my predictions?
JORDAN TIGANI: I would
say start simple.
Logistic regression
is pretty simple.
Linear regression
RandomForest, the decision
trees are pretty simple.
AUDIENCE: Are there
APIs that integrate
those kinds of
regression models?
JORDAN TIGANI: Yes.
So actually one of
the other questioners
just asked about scikit-learn.
Scikit-learn has packages.
You basically just feed your
data in and out comes a model.
And you feed your new data
in, and out comes predictions.
So they make it pretty easy.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: There's
a lot of exploration
you can do with just SQL.
I loaded these data
sets in BigQuery.
So I ran, OK, do as
I was saying earlier.
Countries with a
bigger population
are correlated to
making more goals.
The correlation was zero
until I removed China
from the data set.
And then I got 0.3 correlations.
Then I removed the USA, and
the correlation went up to 0.4.
And that kind of exploration
that you can get data back
in seconds allows you to
see where you should look,
how you should
segment your data.
So for example, there is a big
correlation there if we only
take countries
that call football
'football', for example.
JORDAN TIGANI: But
I think it also
shows that if you're going to
spend time worrying about sort
of building machine
learning models,
the thing you really should
focus most of your time
on, at least at first, is
really features in your data,
being able to clean your
data, like Felipe was saying.
And the actual algorithms
almost don't matter.
At least, they matter in the
noise and a couple percentage
points here and there.
And you can tweak
those and tune those
once you're happy with the
data that they're putting in.
But if you don't have
good data, if there's not
signal in that data, then the
best algorithm in the world
is not going to be able
to predict accurately.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: You get a book.
AUDIENCE: I want
to ask you about
if there are any books that
you recommend about machine
learning-- besides that one--
and also tools besides the two
that were said here at the talk.
JORDAN TIGANI: So for books
for machine learning--
there's Russell
and Norvig is sort
of the standard one
that is awesome.
Peter Norvig is the chief
of research or something
at Google.
And he's pretty brilliant.
And so I highly
recommend that one.
Other tools-- there's
R. R might be easier
to get started with than pandas,
because it has some better
documentation.
But I would take-- there
are some learning data sets.
One's called like Iris
Setosa or something.
It's about predicting
flower genetics.
It could be fun to just
run through an example
and give it a try and find
that it's not all that hard.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure.
So I have a question
about discoveries.
The cool feature
of BigQuery-- this
is a generic question
about BigQuery--
is you can put
data sets in there
and make it open to
everybody, right?
And I know my friend did it,
and he shared it with me.
I mean, he shared the link
with me, so I found it.
But how do you find other--
because we shouldn't all
replicate New York City data.
I have it, he has it, right?
Is there a way to
discover other--
FELIPE HOFFA: So I can
tell you what I do here.
Whenever I find an
interesting data set,
I can upload it to BigQuery.
Once it's in BigQuery, you
can set the public, data
and you can share
with other people.
I have a couple of websites
where I like sharing things.
So if you go to
reddit.com/r/bigquery,
every data set, every news I
learn about these data sets
sharing BigQuery,
I place it there.
So subscribe to that one.
Also my friend, Ilya
Grigorik, also Google,
he has the site bigqueri.es
like big queries.
There we share a lot
of interesting queries
that people write.
Go there, there are really a
lot of interesting data sets.
And my call to action here is,
if you have an interesting data
set, put it on BigQuery,
set it as Public,
and let anyone else
instantly analyze it.
AUDIENCE: But is
there any plan to have
a Google way of doing it?
Like in Fusion Table, you
can just look for public,
and you just give a word, and
it finds all the public ones,
you know what I mean?
JORDAN TIGANI: The BigQuery
team, we take feature requests,
and things the users are
asking for we will build.
We haven't had--
that was something
we had thought users would
want a lot of is discovery.
And then, we didn't get
a lot of requests for it,
so we haven't built it yet.
So we have a public
issue tracker
where you can set
feature requests.
I would encourage you
to request that feature.
And then hopefully, we
can get started on that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
really new to BigQuery.
And I'm also a little
bit late to the section,
so I apologize in advance if
you guys already covered this.
But you used the
example of World Cup.
And I've seen that in some
countries where gambling
is legal, there's lots of
websites that will provide tips
on which teams to bet on.
Have you seen any website using
BigQuery and the prediction
API to give out tips
to people and monetize
that type of service, and if so,
does it match with your ethic?
Or how do you guys
feel about it?
JORDAN TIGANI: We
don't really know
what users are using BigQuery
for unless they tell us
about it.
And as far as I know, there's
nobody that's doing that.
We have people use it for
financial analysis or even
Bitcoin arbitrage.
But no, I haven't heard about
anybody using it for gambling.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then again,
this is not company advice.
Please don't use our
predictions to gamble.
AUDIENCE: Disclaimer--
don't promote it, either.
I'm just wondering.
FELIPE HOFFA: Every time you
use data for decision making,
you're making a prediction.
Every time you make
a decision, you're
gambling on that happening.
So it's not pure gambling.
But yes, we are always
making decisions
and somehow predicting--
AUDIENCE: How accurate would you
say are all those predictions?
You just showed us predictions
of which team is going to win.
Have you guys done
some sort of research
on how many times actually it
was matched to the team that--
JORDAN TIGANI: They're
extremely accurate.
AUDIENCE: Whoa, thank you.
JORDAN TIGANI: I
don't actually know.
I hope they're very good.
They did pretty well
on the training sets,
or on the test set,
the Premiere League.
But time will tell.
We'll see.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool Thanks.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: Thank you.
We have 30 seconds left?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my question was
basically already covered, so--
JORDAN TIGANI: OK.
You just want to book?
AUDIENCE: Quick question, then.
I see you use
Dataflow and Python.
Is it in the pipeline to
support Python and Dataflow?
Because all the examples
were only showing Java.
JORDAN TIGANI: That's
a good question.
I don't know of any plans, but I
don't know of any plans not to.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
The plan with Dataflow is
to be language agnostic.
But we had to start somewhere.
We started with Java.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FELIPE HOFFA: But that's
a good feature request.
JORDAN TIGANI: Sounds
like we're out of time,
but I'm happy to stick around.
Actually, since
Google I/O is over,
I'm happy to ask
any more questions.
Or if people want
me to sign a book,
I'll be happy to sign a book.
FELIPE HOFFA: Its over.
Thank you, very much.
I'll see you next
year, or around.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]